véronique d'oeuf part occupe château de
villesavin depuis 1993 des restaurations
coûteuses ont déjà été entreprises sur
le site
cette fois c'est le colombier du 16e
siècle qui doit faire l'objet d'une
rénovation
donc là vous voyez que effectivement le
la pierre est très dégradé le toit est
en mauvais état la lucarne a été un
petit peu rafistolé avec des planches
qui elle même ne tiennent plus
donc voilà on constate bien qu' il ya un
caractère d'urgence à intervenir sur ce
colombier et pour chaque restauration
entreprise comme ici celle de la salle
de garde ou encore la rénovation des
peintures murales de la chapelle les
châtelains de villesavin n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de faire appel aux
subventions
c'est pas parce qu'on est celle là qu'on
est riche et bien au contraire puisque
tout notre argent en le consacre aux
monuments tout notre temps c'est pareil
on le consacre au monument nous on est
dans des restaurations qui ont sur site
classé qui atteignent des montants qui
sont quand même important pour un petit
monument comme villesavin donc
effectivement c'est plus que précieux
pour nous de pouvoir être dans la liste
finale la deux de la mission stéphane
bern mais c'est sur le site de
villesavin c'est l'un des quatre
monuments du doigt richert à être
présélectionnés pour bénéficier d'une
aide de la fondation du patrimoine
ici en fait on est au coeur de ce que de
ce que peut représenter patrimoine en
france à la fois un très joli château
qui a aussi des pendus finalement d'un
grand château voisin
et puis aussi toute la vie rurale qui
est autour avec ce magnifique colombier
qui est en passe de devenir
malheureusement une ruine si on ne s'y
intéresse pas les travaux du colombier
eux doivent débuter en novembre 2018 et
seuls 40% de leurs financements ont été
recueillis à ce jour